just saying that you're attracted to
some some like your opposite sex that's
not objective that's something that you
actually have to understand that person
and I should be like no wait why no
sexual people there are other parts it's
it's objective reality that there are
men who are attracted to men and there
are women who are attracted to women
because we're so forward thinking now no
no no no no no people didn't want to
upset that it's always whether or not
they accepted it it existed it was just
like it always existed transgender
always existed
no no it didn't no it doesn't
no the feeling that you that you feel
like you
you are under dysphoria you want to
categorize that's what it's called
that's lit by definition this is what
it's called transgenderism is gender
dysphoria exists I've said that